Jew oh hi Oh graduate students have
invented a device they are calling a
Kanna Buster a Kanna buster
this will help law enforcement determine
whether or not drivers are under the
influence of marijuana yeah now they're
already testing the device yeah and you
hear the worry from our audience I know
we get a very specific tiny body here at
the Conan show I say I tell them the
premise and that you're really good here
that people like that's not good people
passing their car keys to their friend
yeah no this is true it's called the can
of Buster these two guys developed it
and apparently it will tell you whether
or not you're under the influence it'll
tell law enforcement whether you're
under the influence of marijuana and
they're testing this thing it really
seems like a simple surefire way to tell
if someone is high behind the wheel take
a look at this
what's up by recessed administration
please
good smoking marijuana no sir
we want to take a test absolutely
[Applause]
[Music]
that must mean I'm high because I didn't
laugh at it dogs dogs picking apples
would make me laugh too